so when i put something out like that or
if there's some kind of comparison to
you to like say casey anthony that's not
my intent to do that but that's what the
audience wants to see
you see what i'm saying so maybe you're
getting the wrong impressions like i'm
not trying to make you look like casey
anthony i just mentioned you in the same
show as casey anthony
okay i guess i just don't usually play
into that
like on my channel i get the clickbaity
stuff but if i'm like doing it probably
no i really don't i definitely have not
made an indirect comparison between
someone and someone who murdered her
child and put her in a trunk
welcome to episode 131 of the michaela
peterson podcast last episode before
2022
i thought i'd stick this episode in as
the last to close off a very weird year
it's featuring rolo tomasi author of
many books including the rational mail i
invited roland to talk about his book
before finding out he'd done a somewhat
nasty in-depth video about what he
thinks my life is like which has about
160 000 views
and i decided to do the interview anyway
because there are a lot of rumors out
there about my life and it's actually
really annoying there's a fairly large
group of people that think i dragged dad
to russia to detox him somehow forced
him on an all-meat diet somehow took
over his brand somehow party all the
time hook up with people etc none of
those rumors are true which will be
clarified more in my book but after
watching rollo's video about the entire
thing with my dad because he was in
nashville and i was setting up courses
to be filmed for him after hearing my
dad's rather loud thoughts on rolo i
decided i'd definitely like to talk to
him anyway clear away some of the mocks
surrounding my name hopefully i hope you
enjoy it and for any of you guys out
there that still think i'm some evil
human praying off of my dad and who
knows what else hopefully this
clarification helps even though it
probably wasn't needed which i'm also
aware of but enough is enough i wanted
to address these topics i didn't edit
this video other than removing about
four seconds of us talking about covid
and adding in clips
before we get into probably the weirdest
episode i've ever recorded
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
we all need help at some point in our
lives whether it's because of stress at
home or work loneliness existential
angst regular angst or listening to a
podcast like this it can be invaluable
to know that there's someone we can talk
to and who's professionally trained to
help us get through whatever it is we're
facing
you've probably heard of better help
over two million people use their online
platform now and it's pretty easy to see
why it removes all the potential hassle
and awkwardness that can be involved in
finding a therapist and gives you some
essential simplified steps instead there
are a broad range of experts available
categorized by their specialty or
combination of specialties for example
addiction social anxiety better health
wants you to start living a happier life
today visit their website and read their
testimonials they'll see dozens upon
dozens of people post daily those kind
of testimonials can be super helpful in
choosing the right therapist and you
wouldn't find anywhere near this amount
of reviews for regular therapists out
there if you're lonely out there there
are people you can talk to these guys
also have a special offer for us get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
peterson join over 2 million people
who've taken charge of their mental
health and with the help of experienced
professionals feel better so many people
have been using it that additional
therapists are being recruited in all 50
states that's better help as in hglp.com
peterson or just use promo code peterson
for 10 off and now
try to enjoy the episode it was
uncomfortable but very interesting
[Music]
first of all welcome to the podcast
thank you
thanks for having me
i've wanted to talk to you for a while
because i heard about your book
you know a long time ago the rational
mail i thought it'd be interesting to
talk to you and so i invited you on last
week after people from the fresh and fit
podcast said
you guys should talk
and it wasn't actually until it was two
days later when i saw that you'd put out
a that like four hour long video on me i
always and
yeah well i thought
so i thought what we should do because i
still want to talk about your book but i
thought we should go over some of the
points in the video because
i think that there's misrepresentation
of who i am on the internet
uh and so some of the things you talked
about in the video
were out of order and weren't quite
right
and so i wanted to go through that
and then get to your book
and i would also like to thank you for
coming on and giving me the opportunity
to do this because i really do
appreciate that
so
let's start i've got some notes here i'm
prepared i was a bit nervous
but i don't buy it so
sure sure
okay so in
i think it was 2019 you sent out a tweet
i believe it was 2019 sent out a tweet
and it had kind of outlined
how you and i think a number of people
on the internet perceived my life it was
long 20 000 people liked it
right um that wasn't me though that was
i didn't put that out it was a it was
somebody actually somebody linked me to
that and uh so maybe you read or
retweeted it well i i didn't even i
don't think i retweeted it i know i
bookmarked it but um but to your point
yes i used that in the video that i did
what about three weeks four weeks ago
okay okay so that could have been wasn't
my i didn't do that i didn't okay
if that's what you think just so just so
you know i was reading no that needed to
be clarified okay okay now this is from
a twitter thread that uh that i was made
familiar with not too long ago um i
think this is in 2020.
this was going on um let me
does that work better i guess that works
better okay here we go so i want to just
give you a quick background here of what
led up to all of this
and again this is not this is not a burn
but i want you to see that the process
is here okay so this is the jordan
i did not do this i am not responsible
for this i don't know who this guy is
rational disconnect but
so
michaela started with the lion diet
which consists of only eating beef salt
and water
although this verges on an eating
disorder michaela claimed that it cured
many of her health problems as we have
heard throughout all of these videos she
even announced that she stopped taking
her medication including an anti-herpes
drug
okay so what's that drug that's this
right here you see that there we go
okay the what what he's mentioning is
the valtrex at the very bottom of that
now what is valtrex valtrex is this
it is used to treat infections caused by
a certain type of virus
in children it is used to treat cold
sores in the mouth
which is a herpes simplex chickenpox
in adults it is used to treat shingles
caused by herpes zoster cold sores
around the mouth and uh is also used to
treat outbreaks of genital herpes so
that was what everybody was was making a
big deal out of back in the day so there
you have that
then she uh then convinced her father to
start uh start her diet soon after
starting jordan reported that he stopped
taking his antidepressants as well
so you've got dad on antidepressants and
you've got daughter on antidepressants
um this were part of the
that thread throw that in there
now this is where i wanted to get to
okay it was around this time
that peterson reported not being able to
sleep for about for 25 days straight
while experiencing
what
an overwhelming sense of impending doom
after drinking some apple cider
but it was just physical oh jesus i was
so dead but i didn't want to not do it
cider like what was it
what was it doing
oh it it it produced an
overwhelming sense of impending doom
and i seriously been overwhelming like
there's no way i could have lived like
that if that would have lasted for
see michaela knew by that point that it
would probably only last a month and i
was like a month yeah [ __ ] cider
oh i didn't sleep that that month i
didn't sleep for 25 days i didn't sleep
at all i didn't sleep at all for 25 days
how's that possible
i'll tell you how it's possible you lay
in bed uh frozen in something
approximating terror for eight hours and
then you get up oh my god oh yeah and
this is from [ __ ] cider from science
that's what we thought yeah i mean look
again
i don't know what the hell i'm talking
about
i'm i'm ending it there because that's
where the clip ends okay
if you want to see that also available
on uh joe rogan's show all right let's
keep going it was because of this
anxiety caused by a severe autoimmune
reaction to food
quote unquote that uh jordan was
prescribed benzos benzes okay
benzodiazepine
which was uh increased after his wife
was diagnosed with cancer this led to
peterson's developing a physical
dependence on the medication
again you can read this later i'll put
this in now
why this is not to beat up on
the family here i know it probably
sounds like i am but i have to sort of
lead up to this so you know where we're
going when we get to the kill-to-party
dynamic here okay
according to michaela after multiple
failed rehabs attempt rehab attempts she
claims
almost killed him peterson was moved to
russia for alternative treatments
the unknown treatment put peterson into
a medically induced coma for eight days
and gave him neurological damage so if
you think that peterson is not quite the
same peterson as he was back in 2018
that might be why
now here we go in the middle of her
father's hospitalization michaela left
her husband and dad to travel around
romania with andrew tate
his words not mine a misogynist pickup
artist which
is not but and webcam pimp who runs a
scam website and thinks that depression
doesn't exist
and of course that's when you get the
infamous picture here
and you get
the one that i showed you just not too
long ago
where she's hanging out
enjoying herself and i'm going to just
throw this i'll throw this other one up
here in just a second um
this is
the infamous picture
right there
that doesn't look like a girl who's like
fearful that her dad's going to die or
worried about what her husband is
thinking uh in any sense again no hate
on tight no hate on tape hey tate's
gonna do what tate's gonna do
however
here you have michaela peterson taking
time out of her busy schedule and her
father's medical regimen who's in a
medically induced coma
to go to romania and hang out with the
tates
or at least him oh we'll come back to
that home a little premature that's the
one i wanted right there this was
another one again this is when everybody
hits up on the tates about like his
connection with michaela that's what
everybody gets to
just
throwing that out there side note
michaela's husband is from russia
thus andre right
claims to be possessed by a demon named
igor
and is the one who helped makayla get
her dad into russia for those treatments
next this time this entire time michaela
was charging people fifty to six hundred
dollars for memberships to her diet
website that offered virtually nothing
the site is now defunct for a second
time and was basically just a support
group for people claiming that the diet
cured them but does it work for anyone
you guys can again that's kind of
immaterial to everything that's going on
um well it apparently didn't work for
her father as we have already seen it
didn't work for her because she admitted
that she also took anti-anxiety drugs
while on her diet and it didn't help her
mother who was diet who was on the diet
and was diagnosed with kidney cancer
requiring two surgeries again that's
immaterial to what we're talking about
here
and then last but not least um
peterson finishes treatment in russia
they went to florida and eventually
ended up in serbia where michaela gave
her entire family covid hospitalizing
jordan yet again
and the crazy thing is that as far as i
can tell jordan hasn't talked directly
to the media since 2019 all updates have
come through starter now that of course
this was back in 2020 so
take that to be whatever you want to
want it to be
well a couple of things then just in
regards to your video a number of weeks
ago
so
first i think i should address the
andrew tate situation
listen let's listen
she's a nice lady nothing happened i
spoke to her a bit
she was in germany i think i said hey
germany's romania is not so far away
come visit we'll go see some castles
it'll be fun we'll jump in one of my 17
supercars
and that's what we did that's the story
translation i [ __ ] the shout out
she's a nicer she's a nice girl she's a
nice girl and uh
that's it i'm i i'm not really a fan of
her dads i know her dad said some smart
stuff and i know he said some cool stuff
i've seen a couple clips i'm not a super
fan or nothing i've never watched him
from head to toe or anything like that
um
but yeah it is what it is that's all
that's all it is i'm not going to say
any more than that so sorry sorry boring
answer but that's the answer
there you go there's our good friend
so
before i went to russia this was october
before my dad is was in the hospital
before i went to russia i was in germany
and andrew tate invited me to come
see his house and talk business
and he flew me over there
for a day
i was there for a day
he was talking about starting a pay wall
trying to figure out how to monetize
content
and then i flew home
and so we took a couple of photos one's
in the cigar lounge
but just because i flew over there and
talked to him doesn't mean there was
anything sexual that occurred which is
what happened when the internet saw that
photo which of course is what andrew has
said on pretty much any time i've taught
i actually interviewed him right after
that because of course everybody wants
to know what was going on right so when
you put something yeah out at that time
um that's what everybody's gonna gonna
say and he's pretty much said exactly
what you have said as well so
um in fact i think i even mentioned that
i i pointed it out in the fresh and fit
video as a matter of fact where they
were interviewing him about that about
that those i guess there's a couple of
pictures
um but you got it there's a bit of
inference that maybe something had
occurred so i just wanted to set that
straight right right so so that's the
first thing um the second thing is can i
can i ask yeah yeah okay um so that was
in october of 2019
and you were in germany 2019.
so you were already in germany at that
time
yeah i'd been in germany
i'd flew from toronto to germany i was
in germany for business and then on the
way home i stopped in romania for a day
okay
and then
january i can't remember that might have
been 2018. but he flew you out there
correct
on the way back yes
from germany to romania or all the way
germany to romania and then romania to
canada okay it's like i'm busy but
i'll come see i was interested in what
he's done he's made a lot of money he's
put things behind a paywall and i kind
of wanted to learn
he seems like an interesting character
so i thought that could be interesting
were you aware what he does for a living
no
he told me once he got there it's not
like he was hiding anything how did you
guys like meet
like online oh over instagram okay
yeah during 2019 i guess
i can't if that was 2019 or 2018
um
that would have been 2018 october 2018 i
think because 2019 it was january 2019
hopefully i'm getting the year right
when i went to russia with my dad
yeah
no sorry no 2019 is right and then it
was 2020 we went to russia with dad so
in your video you said oh she brought
her dad to russia and then while he was
in the hospital went off and you know
partied with andrew tate which wasn't
right because that was four months
earlier three months earlier
i just wanted to clarify that well
that's the information that i had
available to me
yeah well he tweeted the photo out three
or four months later but i mean photos
can be taken whenever and then tweet it
out later
uh so
that's the first thing i wanted to
address and then
you okay so a couple of things
i think part of the reason maybe it
feels like you have
something against me or you think i'm
one of those women that doesn't want to
have kids or didn't want a kid in the
first place
and going back to my tom bill you
podcast where i say having scarlet put a
kibosh on my life i just wanted to
clarify i did not mean having the kid
was the issue
the best place to start to explain that
is in a day and age where people are
having kids later and later and later in
life you chose as a ambitious person as
far as i can tell to have kids in your
20s
so why don't we start there how
thoughtful was that was that accidental
was it something you put a lot of
thought into
oh that's an interesting place to start
that is a very complicated story
actually
scarlet was an accident so i was in
university
i'd done two years in psychology and
then i'd switched over to biomedical
science and i was in my second year
and i got pregnant and i
kept her because i couldn't
emotionally handle any other option
and it was
extremely stressful because i was so i
was 23 when i got pregnant and my
life plan was to have kids
ideally before the age of 30
but i'm also like you said very career
oriented and i was
in my second year of university so that
was not ideal for you know when to have
a kid
but
but i decided to keep her and i ended up
dropping out of university
and then
doing part-time work for my dad and
which turned into full-time work very
rapidly when scarlet was about six
months old but
the choice to
have
i didn't really feel like i had a choice
like i i ended up um when i when i got
healthy i stopped taking all my
medication including birth control
because you were worried about what it
was doing to you from a gut perspective
yeah well not even from a from a gut
perspective but also from a
psychological perspective like my mom
told me that when she'd gone on birth
control it had made her severely
depressed and she hadn't recognized that
until she stopped taking it
and i kind of laughed that off but i
started taking birth control when i was
14
and i was severely depressed so
hoop earrings uh duly noted thank you
very much uh oh by the way this
interview is with uh what'd you say his
name was uh tom bilyeu that's what it
was uh and this was from july 8th i i
should have told you the date before i
started this but this was on july 8th of
this year
i thought who cares if you add another
pill on top of it i'm already depressed
um which was like an immature way of
thinking about it
uh as a 14 year old might but when i was
23 and i stopped taking my medications
and i got healthier i was like i don't
want anything impacting my mental
function
and so i stopped taking birth control
just in case it was and i do believe
that i was having um i do believe it was
causing depression
but it wasn't the only thing in my life
that was causing depression at that
point but yeah i did stop taking it and
that ended up resulting in scarlet who
i'm thrilled to have but it definitely
put a bit of a
kibosh on the direction i thought my
life was going to take however it ended
up not being a negative thing it ended
up being a positive thing but it was
scary
yeah there's a lot of interesting stuff
in that so one it put a kibosh on my
personal life sound like killed a party
sure does to me
now i'm not saying she's going to kill
her child obviously she's not however
that is the motivation that's what i'm
talking about
is the hindrance factor i meant that i'd
had this plan in my head where i went to
university and was able to support
myself because of my university degree
and i chose to have scarlet and had to
rearrange my life around that but going
back i would not change that decision i
would have changed the decision to get
married
because i wasn't in a good relationship
so it had nothing it wasn't scarlet that
was the issue there it was that i
shouldn't have
gotten married to someone i wasn't
supposed to be with that wasn't a good
match
because that wasn't good for anybody
that was the mistake
it wasn't scarlet so i wanted to clarify
that in case it sounded like
going back oh i wouldn't have had a kid
well when when i was covering that
aspect of in that show when i was
covering that aspect and i was looking
at whether tom billy i hope i'm saying
his name right yeah um
i mean in that episode you mentioned
that scarlet was an accident
was like certainly an unplanned
pregnancy let's just be honest
um so
and you were what 23 24 when that
happened 33 yeah yeah so what i was
doing again i think a lot of people when
they watch that they think that i was
making a hit piece or an attack piece on
you i was trying to use you as well as
brittany renner uh was it uh tommy laron
uh
several other examples as well you your
name happened to be one of them and it
was illustrating an example
of how
children end up being a hindrance to a
woman she wasn't quite she wasn't a
hindrance though that's what i wanted to
clarify
she wasn't a hindrance like that stopped
me from going to university but
if i went back and didn't have scarlet
not going to university was actually the
right decision going to university and
getting the degree i was getting
wouldn't have helped me out anyway
so
yeah when you have a kid parts of your
life are harder to do like yeah i
couldn't go out and drink every weekend
but that's not a fulfilling life anyway
so
hindrance would it have been a
fulfilling life at 23 rather than 29.
like i said i wouldn't go back what i
would have changed is i shouldn't have
gotten married because that caused a
whole bunch of problems and
that's that was the issue do you think
you should have had the kid out of
wedlock then because and in the todd the
reason i asked see this is tom bill you
in interview and you were saying you
didn't want to be an unmarried mother no
i didn't and that's the problem i had
when i was 23. i was like okay
i have an unplanned
pregnancy
and the most stable way to raise a child
is in a
family with a man and a woman i agree
and so bite the bullet get married and
figure out how to make it work and
negotiate until you have a proper
relationship
and so
that was my thinking when i was 23
and
i wasn't able to negotiate that
relationship
and
i suppose every divorce you know it's
always the
other person who's in the wrong so i
don't know how that works exactly or
what my point is but
that was not a good like that was not a
good place to be and what i ended up
deciding um and it wasn't actually this
year when we decided to get divorced we
decided to get divorced in in 2018.
but it got stretched out for a number of
years and i can get into that if i need
to
but the reason
the reason it took
no
um part of the reason it took a while is
because i wanted to be absolutely sure
that breaking up the family was better
for everyone
and not just for me
is it
yes 100 everybody is happy your
positions kind of changed then since 23
years 23 year old versus what are you 29
you'll be 30 next year right
um
yeah my positions change my position
hasn't changed that a two-parent family
is healthier for a kid but a two-parent
family that's fighting all the time
isn't healthier than being separated and
not being filled in a house that's full
of resentment and anger
now because now correct me if i'm wrong
because i'm i don't know him personally
but it seems by all
let's just say impressions that andre is
pretty good with with your daughter
andre's very andre is very good with my
very i mean
you have to understand the impression
that i have and pretty much everybody
else has when we're seeing nothing but
instagram shots of andre with the kid
and you off doing what with the tates
first of all and then second of all um
you know doing doing what you're doing
right now um so well is it part of the
is there something else like that that
people don't know that
that you know well it's like he's not
he's not as good as the impressions are
because i'm
certainly not gonna
i'm certainly not gonna say anything
negative about andre like ever period
so so that's just bottom line but part
of the reason i don't have scarlet all
over my instagram is because i have tons
of followers he has her own private
account and my extended family follows
that private account so if i do put up a
picture of her her private account is
tagged but i don't let people who don't
know or follow her
[Music]
so that's that's part of the reason okay
yeah i just didn't wasn't sure like at
the beginning when she was really little
there were pictures of her up on my
instagram if you scroll all the way down
baby pictures and then when she got a
bit older it was like i don't know if
maybe that's appropriate or not so i
made her a private account
when um so you were mentioning that you
had already decided that you were going
to like at least separate or because i
know you were on a break
at the time that you were in romania
with
the tates at that time and i think i've
been pretty public about that so i don't
think i'm revealing anything there um so
as far back as at least 2018 you were
already making plans or you'd already
discussed divorcing or separating is
that what i'm getting
okay 2018 and then
and then what happened was
we were living separately
and
my parents got really sick
[Music]
and
andre ended up and i know that this can
come across as using him
but this was a very complicated
situation my parents were in the
hospital over the summer i was taking
care of them like i ended up
andre went away so we were living
separately andre went away for about a
month he was in russia and i was
taking care of scarlet and then
after my mom had surgery for cancer
getting a babysitter going over there in
the morning
grabbing scarlett after she had a nanny
putting her to bed getting another
babysitter going back to take care of my
mom
so that was one of the months
and then andre came back saw that i was
in really rough shape from all the
stress he started helping
and that was the summer and then my dad
got really sick
from benzodiazepine dependence in a side
effect called akathesia which
makes people suicidal
and so he was suicidal and
he went to rehab because we thought the
best way to deal with this was rehab
which wasn't right because they tried
stabilizing him with more medications
and because of those medications
this is yeah well
yes so we went to like we you know spent
a bunch of money went to a private like
the best rehab center and they ended up
just stabilizing him putting him on more
medications the academia got worse
and so
he was there
brought him back to canada
and then he ended up in the hospital in
december
so that was
19 december 2019
and in the hospital they
sedated him with medications to
counteract this academia
so badly that when we went in there he
couldn't communicate very well
and
my whole family flew down so my aunt my
uncle my grandparents everybody flew
down and we all talked about it and we
had been researching all over the world
to figure out where to bring him that
wouldn't keep adding on medications that
would just take them away
and the only place that looked honestly
kind of crazy enough to do that was
russia
and we went everywhere like i didn't
want to go to russia because i don't
speak russian and russia's terrifying so
i didn't want to do that but we tried
israel but they've got the same kind of
medical establishment where they just
keep adding on medications to stabilize
which doesn't work for academia because
it's a side effect
anyway so
the only way to get into russia and
andre was helping me at this point
because
my dad was in such bad shape in a
hospital that the fact that we were
getting divorced didn't seem as dramatic
as it normally would because we were
dealing with somebody who we thought was
going to be in the hospital and then die
we were like okay
the divorce is a thing but
at this point you know
it was falling apart
yeah
so
we ended up
going to russia and we ended up getting
back together
but for the next
year
and a half
we just did primary care for my dad so
when we went to russia and he had his
detox
it was
the worst period of my entire life and
online
i was just shown as this person who had
you know
put forced my dad onto my weird all meat
diet
and then dragged him to russia and
nearly killed him while gallivanting off
with other people
and that was when that tweet went out
which wasn't yours that twenty thousand
people liked and i was in russian like
my hair was falling out from stress i
couldn't communicate very well with
people because i don't speak russian i
was like this is it's either this or
dad's in this hospital and he's gonna
die and my entire extended family agreed
on that
so
that's the background there
um
so andre was instrumental in getting him
into russia and we wouldn't have been
able to we wouldn't have been able to
get him into russia without andre
because he had a russian passport oh
okay
but but it wasn't just it wasn't just
that like he
was with me helping take care of my dad
and i was
yeah
and so he was instrumental there so
people are online were like why aren't
you and even my dad why aren't you with
someone who's like a good dad he's he's
helping your family
um
and
i don't really want to like i don't
want to get into the negatives because
i don't think it's appropriate but we
fought all the time in ways that i
couldn't negotiate and i don't think i'm
an unreasonable person
and so the stress in our household
was really bad and i didn't think it was
good for scarlet either
and so separately
things are working out we're
communicating
and like i said i'm not going to like it
i'm not gonna
villainize my kid's dad
like ever
yeah
especially publicly so yeah
i get it i get it but i'm i'm i'm
curious to know like i mean you have to
go into details or anything like that
but
i mean i have seen interviews of you
well i think it was you and your mother
or something like that talking about how
you know building a relationship and
building that marriage or do you think
that that wasn't possible with andre
no it wasn't possible
okay was because
uh is there
is he about the same i don't know how
old he is is it about the is he in his
20s as well
no he's 31.
so he's 31 okay so he's just a touch
older than you yeah correct okay
well i was curious because i i mean a
lot of a lot of what i see on your
channel here
is really kind of
you know i guess relationship building
and particularly when you do interviews
with your mother you deal with your
father
it's it seems to me like it's it's
counter-intuitive let's just say to what
you is you know you portray on your on
your channel so i was just wondering is
it is it something that's just like
fundamentally a conflict that you can't
resolve or is it something that's like
just because you are at a certain age
because as you were saying before when
you were 23 you were thinking different
than you are now at 29. so is uh no
discount okay i i get i get what you're
saying no i don't think it's an age
thing i think it took me a while to
realize that andre and i weren't
compatible i've wanted to have kids and
have a family since i was like 16 and i
wanted to do that young so 23 and you
talk about it on your channel 23 is a
good age to do that you talk about
wanting to party in missing years but
i had a rough teenage
hood
i drank a lot i was not happy when that
girl gets into her you know party or
party years or whatever else then it's
fomo
and it's yolo okay
yolo not rollo yolo you only live once
and fear of missing out
and michaela peterson is now
experiencing the fear of missing out
like i don't need to continue drinking
in order to fill some
you know fomo that i'm experiencing i'm
not experiencing fomo from partying i
don't drink
right like i wake up at six in the
morning i think the last time i had i
had a couple of drinks on halloween
but
it's not my age that's changing how i
feel if anything i'm more upset now
because now i'm 29
and this would have been
better to have sorted out when i was 24.
you talk about that too that like women
decline with age especially with
fertility so
no i would say it's it's the opposite
that is what i want like what i do want
is a family and a stable relationship
i'm not interested in hooking up with
people
people are gross in general like i don't
agree i'm not
um
so
i i think the i think the main issue i
had with your video
because i can understand how i come off
online and i haven't really figured out
how to address that i've kind of been
ignoring it been like well that's a
problem but i'll just keep going to see
what happens um but i didn't like the
comparison
that you made between me and what is her
name casey anthony who
murdered her kid and then put her in the
trunk so that she could go party
i thought that was not very nice
what the kill to party dynamic is this
is that when a woman has a child
especially when they have them earlier
on such as michaela peterson here
that child becomes a hindrance to
optimizing hypergamy that is in a
nutshell
what the kill to party dynamic is about
so
when
we talk about how guys should not um
date single mothers for example when
when rich cooper or myself or anyone
else for that matter
says avoid single mothers well most guys
do kind of
naturally oh thank you for that uh
sammy let me go and put that on there
that's actually a pretty good shot
sammy has come through
with the where'd it go there we go let's
see how this is our good this is uh this
is k uh casey anthony all right where'd
she go
where's my casey there's my casey
can we see casey there she is
2008 yeah gosh that was it that long ago
police in orange county
florida uh received a call that led to
one of america's most high profile
criminal cases that just oh that was
when she did it the disappearance and
death of two-year-old kaylee anthony i
guess it was her daughter my bad um and
the question of whether her mother casey
anthony
the other one i guess
was involved there we go okay so that's
that's our good friend casey anthony in
case you wanted a visual reference of
what what is i'm actually talking about
here
and i okay so let me i'll explain a
couple things to you here first um i'll
get to the epiphany phase in just a
second but
um when i brought up casey anthony i was
using that as the most extreme example
of what i call the kill to party dynamic
okay and what that is is that women who
have their children much younger
realize that is a an obstacle it is a
hindrance to them
seeking out and finding another partner
finding a guy who is better off for what
they think at least at that time is
would be a have been a better pairing
for them
while they are still within that sort of
threshold of say like 18 to 28 years old
where i call it the party years other
people call it the whole phase whatever
you want to call you know when you're
having your fun and you're you know it's
it's when you can um
uh
when you can build things a little bit
more when women are at their prime
agency like i said before like we're
just like in a second ago is 23 is where
i peg most women at being that their
sexual market value peak years i say
that for a number of reasons um
primarily it's because that's when men
find women the most attractive right
during that sort of 18 to 28 era
however when women have a child such as
you at 23 years old it tends to put a
damper on finding a guy who's better
than say the guy that they ended up
divorcing or the guy that they ended up
marrying and then divorcing during that
time so that was the example that i was
using i think what happens is this is
when i do something like that when i
when i use an example such as kcm i'm
not seeing and i even said this i don't
know how many times during that that
four hour video i'm not saying that
that's what you wanted to do okay i'm
just using casey anthony as one prime
example of that i used other examples as
well brittany renner for example
locking down pj washington with the kid
when when the time was right for hershey
of course is 29 years old as well um so
i was using her as an example but people
hone in on something as extreme as say
like casey anthony i tried to present
the fact that that was the extreme
example of that
however
the more general example of that dynamic
is that when women have are become
single mothers particularly when they
become single mothers at an early age it
makes them less marketable in the sexual
marketplace
that's what i was getting at but of
course everyone in the comments goes he
just compared you to casey anthony well
the thumbnail the thumbnail did have me
and i do thank you for picking a good
picture of me by the way but it didn't
have me and then kill to party well let
me explain to you the dynamics of
thumbnail
creation which maybe you already know
but when you put people's face on there
when you put people's recognizable faces
on there when you have to see the whites
of their eyes and you're not the first
one i've ever done this with by the way
that's simply how you get impressions on
youtube right now i'm you know i'll i'll
be all above board with that because i'm
not the first one to to figure this out
and oh definitely so so when you do
something like that then it gets then it
draws like i've said this before it's
like i understand that there's a
salaciousness there's the tmz effect
right it's the it's uh you want to give
give your audience the red meat however
when i do so i'm trying to give them
steak with the sizzle so i'm not doing
it just to say oh look here here's what
she did right that's
that's not my point i say that in the
beginning of every single one of my
videos
especially when i go after somebody who
i i think would make a good example of a
particular like illustration of a
dynamic that i'm talking about i talked
about uh emma was there emma thorne i
think is what her name was i talked
about her on a couple of different
occasions um and you know people don't
have a problem with that because that's
him with born and then you're michaela
peterson so when i do a thumbnail like
of her nobody's saying oh you just
compare he you know he just compared
youtube such and such it's not an attack
piece video i don't try to do i don't do
reaction videos i don't do like takedown
videos or anything like that if i think
that somebody serves as a good
illustration for a dynamic that i've
written about in the past or that i'm
talking about currently you know with
whatever that i'm doing then yes i'll do
that because it's a recognizable say oh
okay now i get what he's saying so it's
more of like an illustration rather than
like oh i'm gonna take you down in every
single video that i do this in i put out
the standard caveat this is not about
the individual this is about what's
going on so let's talk about what the
dynamic is not about it's not an attack
but this is youtube
this is twitter this is instagram this
is social media so everybody wants to
see like what we call a youtube
bloodsport they want to see like oh did
you see that he compared you to this did
you see you compared to that i talked
about this uh recently on um on elijah
schaefer's show as well so um it's it's
there's this
um i think there's this need for people
to have sort of this
get a rise out of you i was on i was on
you are here with elijah shaffer and
sydney watson and uh arielle i forget
her last name scarcella or scarella
she's the you know lesbian uh you know
uh traditional conservative i guess now
and
when i was on there and we were having
our back and forth everyone in the chat
wanted us to like be at each other's
throats right because they're looking
for this it's bread and circuses
so when i put something out like that or
if there's some kind of comparison to
you to like say casey anthony that's not
my intent to do that but that's what the
audience wants to see
you see what i'm saying so maybe you're
getting the wrong impressions like i'm
not trying to make you look like casey
anthony i just mentioned you in the same
show as
casey anthony
okay i guess i just don't usually play
into that
like on my channel i get the clickbaity
stuff but if i'm like doing it probably
no i really don't as you're doing it
though no i really don't i definitely
have not made an indirect comparison
between someone and someone who murdered
her child and put her in a trunk well
that was not my intent anyways okay well
i'm really glad to hear that that makes
me feel better and then let's see what
else do i have then we can get to your
book okay finding god as convenient my
problem isn't the actual sincerity of
the belief i mean they can say whatever
they want we can decide to believe it or
not women get off scot-free because
we're not supposed to be judgmental
god forbid a guy be judgmental that by
the way being judgmental is the cardinal
sin of the new the new world religion
which is emotionalism which is femaleism
right
be judgmental and that is a sin you need
to atone for my friend
and you know what the worst one is is
not believing women believe all women if
you don't believe all women that's a sin
why because you're judging them
because you have some sort of
discernment you go you know that sounds
like [ __ ] to me how dare you judge
me like that
be more judgmental i've said this over
and over and over again i really gotta
do a full show on judgment
i would like to say
i mean it's convenient for me because i
feel significantly better than i did but
the convenience i guess from the outside
view would be oh she finds god and then
suddenly she's getting divorced and
forgive all her past sins because
christianity is about forgiveness and
there's the convenience there but
we've been getting divorced extremely
slowly since 2018 and part of the reason
it was slow was because of this
absolute catastrophe that occurred with
my mom and my
dad so
i understand that you have your whole
like epiphany phase and i can see the
pattern there
[Music]
but i think you want me to explain
what
well it's just like is it convenient
does that just an age when people find
religion or is it would they fake
fake finding religion
i believe that it's uh
i believe that it is when women find
their find religion they get back with
uh they want to sort of rediscover
their roots once they get to the point
where as i said before like the 18 to 28
year
range whatever the whole phase of the
party years whatever you want to call it
right around the time when women hit
about 29 years old 29 to 31 right in
that that range is what i call the
epiphany phase and the epiphany is this
i had an epiphany that suddenly i need
to get right with god i need to make
guys uh do i'm going to do things the
right way i had my fun in the past and
now i'm going to get serious you will
see this constantly again this is not me
just pulling this out of my ass here you
will see this constantly in tinder or
tinder profiles you'll see this
constantly in hinge bumble with the
dating profile name the name the the
platform and you will see women of that
age right around 29 to 31 years old all
of the profiles are very similar which
is i had my fun in the past i'm done
with the jerks i'm done with the
yeah i was so crazy in my college years
um looking for something serious if
you're not looking for something serious
swipe left
you probably understand what i'm saying
it's so common that i can go on like the
guys that i follow or the people who are
sort of in my sphere of influence i
guess
um constantly come up with you know the
screen caps of exactly that same thing
now i i
developed i guess this idea as far back
as like say 2010
so when i put it in my my book
the rational mail in well i published in
2013 but from discussions that i had
prior to publishing that book that's
what we called the epiphany phase and
the epiphany phase is this they come
women come to an epiphany at right
around 29 years old that they can no
longer compete in the sexual marketplace
like they used to in the past
and so now there is this
i think psychological need for women to
find some sort of rationalization to
explain why they did what they did
between the ages of say 18 and 28 and
why they want to go ahead and find a
long-term mate after that and usually
that comes with a rediscovering of
religion
usually that comes with a new
record i guess prerequisites for guys
to jump through certain hoops to qualify
to to
to women's demands i guess or women's
standards let's just say for the long
term
so prior to the epiphany phase
it was more about sort of alpha seed
after uh after the epiphany phase is
more beta need
and i define that it's of course and
your father knows this as well that's
that is hypergamy okay so hypergamy is
this it's alpha seed and beta need and
too many people
tend to focus on just the beta needs
side of things so because it sounds
right it sounds good right oh she found
god that sounds good great come back to
the fold right uh she's had her journey
of self-discovery now she wants to like
do things the right way we're going to
do this the right way now and so at
right around 29 to 31 years old is is at
that what i call that the epiphany phase
and after that you know all bets are off
i guess but right then it's when women
are acknowledging that they can no
longer compete
in at the same level that they could
when they were 23 years old so now
things sort of change and there's this
sort of convenient rationalization of
getting back and i'm not saying that you
didn't sincerely find god i'm just
saying i'm talking about the convenience
of it or the timing of it because people
have hit me up on this before and i'll
explain this right now people will say
well don't you think well don't you
think that that women are actually
sincerely
um you know finding god at this point or
are they aren't they sincerely having
some sort of like uh personal
transformation and i say yeah i do
believe that i think that if you right
now if you took a polygraph test that
say do you sincerely believe what you
believe you probably passed the
polygraph test but i'm what i'm focusing
on is the convenience and the timing of
that particular
epiphany at that at that stage of
maturity for women because it is so
constant that i think that men need to
be aware of that so that's why i say
that now the the god aspect of all this
and i don't know if you are aware but my
fourth book is the rational male
religion and i've talked about red pill
aspects in the course of religion
now i'm not a theologian i have enough
kind of seminary i don't have a degree
in any of this but i'm a keen observer
of human nature and and evolutionary
psychology i have a little bit of a
background in religion but not not
certainly not like your father okay so
that being my caveat there
when we talk about people finding
religion roosh v is i don't familiar
with roosh but roof is like recently
watched and said recently it's like more
like two or three years ago now
has you know decided that he wants to
become an orthodox christian and give up
his sort of pick up his ways and you
know he's sort of i don't see he's a
hermit but he's kind of you know decided
that he's going to isolate himself and
so suddenly at 40 years old he's decided
that he's going to you know rediscover
god and he's you know that's all he
wants to talk about and yes i understand
that his sister died and yes i know that
there was a set of circumstances that
pushed him to that particular time
however that's not what i focus on what
i focus on is what i call the prodigal
son dynamic which is you were once
away from the faith you were partying
and drinking and having all your fun at
hookers and blow right you left your
father's house and you went off to seek
your fortune and it didn't work out the
way that you wanted it to and now you
come back
and you say oh you know what i've
rediscovered god i want to come back to
the family i don't care i'll go eat with
the pigs or whatever and
and the father and
the family all welcome you back with
open arms right if the prodigal son
story is not about the prodigal son it
is about the father and it is about the
the family that welcomed the sun back
because what happens is when you have
that prodigal son dynamic going on or
the prodigal daughter in this case
it's a reaffirmation of faith
for the people who are already
always with that faith so they're happy
to bring you back in and particularly
with christianity it's based on
forgiveness so when you combine the
prodigal son with forgiveness yeah of
course it doesn't matter keep coming
back in go go out with you know go out
seek your fortune fall flat on your face
and come right back it's a reaffirmation
of the faith for the people who are all
who never left the fold and so that's
why i wanted to point out the fact that
when women or even in this case guys
depending on on what their case is when
they rely on that prodigal son dynamic
it's the people who are it's not the guy
it's the it's the people who are
welcoming that person back because it
reaffirms their faith
okay okay
i think i have i've got a couple of
comments for that
um one
okay one how do you know that if there
is some sort of pattern about women
finding god around the age of 29 how do
you know that's not just a stage of
brain development
and do you know what age it happens for
men
i would pretty much gather that it's not
so much brain development um i know that
uh i know that right up until about 21
years old human beings brains are
developing right up until that point
well for men it's 26.
for women 24 24 26 women mature
physically faster than men understood
so
i mean at that point whatever you're i'm
not not saying that maybe you don't have
uh
i'm not i'm not maybe brain development
is wrong but
i'm not doubting the sincerity once
again i'm just saying i'm what i'm
saying is that it comes at a convenient
time when we look at uh if you go and
you look at marriage statistics right
now the the average age of first
marriage for certainly women and well
women in the united states is
28.7 and for men it's like 29.8 like
almost 30 years old and it's older than
that in the uk even so i also point this
out but nobody wants to talk about this
because it's not just like you know
sensational but i point out the fact
that
at that stage it also coincides with
exactly what i talk about in the
epiphany phase now i got to settle down
now now i don't have the options that i
used to have
back when i was 23 years old i can't
compete in the sexual marketplace with
my my 33 year old self cannot compete
with my 23 year old self in the sexual
marketplace when it comes to women at
least and that is right around the time
and again it's that's the point at which
women say i want to
my biological clock is ticking right
here you don't hear women complain about
men being sort of infantile or wanting
to you know afraid of strong you know
threatened by strong independent women
you don't hear women of 23 saying those
things i did 33 and you hear them at 34
but you don't hear them when women are
in the midst of their peak sexual agency
in their lives so when they get to a
point where all the chips are down
that's when it's men aren't measuring up
i can't find an economically attractive
man um and i can't find a guy who is uh
you know right with god or i can't find
a guy who wants to be who wants to date
and marry a single mother it not it's
not my fault it's not my decisions it's
those guys who won't man up it's those
guys who won't take responsibility and
absolve me of the consequences of my
decisions that i made that are now
coming into effect at 30 33 years old
yeah okay so i i get i completely
understand where you're coming from but
i think you're lumping me into a
category of women i don't exist in i was
complaining about
men not wanting to get married when i
was 21. like i've wanted a stable family
like i said since i was 16. as for
competing in the sexual marketplace
my like i understand i'm older but
that's not my issue right i'm not going
to have a problem there do you
understand that as a single mother
your let's just say competitiveness
maybe i should now i hate to commodify
everything for you here but
your
your value as a woman is less than
somebody who does not have kids and if
you're looking at 20 you're soon to be
30 years old if you're looking for that
long-term relationship which you've said
you
are
looking for a guy who's like at your age
or older the men who will be looking for
what you're looking for aren't looking
for you
they're looking for women who are much
younger than you who do not have kids do
you
acknowledge that do you understand that
well you seem to think that every woman
is exactly the same no i think
like yeah if they're gonna find
commonalities for sure
yeah
but i'm not the same kind of person as
the woman you're talking about i don't
have an iq of a hundred
i'm not a [ __ ] i'm fairly attractive i
don't think i'm gonna have an issue and
what i did decide obviously this was a
concern of mine right like clearly
single mom that's not like no one's plan
is that right but i decided that the
situation i was in here no
britney renner planned it so
oh wow that doesn't seem like a wise
decision
but uh what i decided from the situation
i was in was that i would rather be by
myself
and so i would just wrap my head around
being by myself
and so that wasn't my my concern wasn't
a hypergamy i'm gonna go find someone
you know older wiser smarter better
richer you know and do that i just
figured hey i'll just hunker down and
work at least i'll be happier by myself
so you have no plans to
find a long-term husband in the future
though no that's what i want i just
think it's going to be difficult
okay do you realize what statistically
speaking here now i'm just dragging out
you know raw numbers here statistically
speaking do you understand
the odds of you finding that
right now
in today's sexual marketplace
do you know the odds of fighting do you
know do you know the odds of finding
somebody if you have an iq above 115 or
130 as well i know it's yeah it just
gets worse so then single mom age
higher iq yeah it's going to be an issue
of course that's what i want i told you
yeah it is it is tough but i mean it's
and it only gets and it only gets
tougher the older you get you realize
definitely i would assume i don't think
i don't think
i don't think i'm like being again
your father always said you know to you
have to risk being offensive to like
have critical debates so i'm not trying
to like kick you in the ass no it's okay
this is why you're on here yeah
so this is why you're on here so my my
point is is that
and when you go i know you're are you
still scheduled to go on fresh and fit
like later on i think next month yeah
february i think okay so i'm going to
i'm going to prep you for here's here's
your preparation for fresh and fit
because myron's gonna bring up the same
exact thing that i'm saying to you right
now which is as a woman gets older her
value declines her value decreases a
woman's primary agency in life is her
sexual marketability that's not personal
value okay so it's very important that
you like as most women conflate sexual
market value with
their personal worth right mother teresa
fantastic human being you know let's
let's make her a saint right her sexual
market value let's just be honest okay
however so there's a def i'm using again
extreme examples right i'm using her as
an example here to say that there's a
separation between sexual market value
and
personal worth and that's i think is one
of the primary problems that women have
today because they're like you they say
you know what there's the uh the
incident or i say the enrollment for you
know higher education right now women
are enrolling in record numbers in in
college um i certainly outclassing men
at this point i don't think i'm this is
any kind of revelation for anyone here
but men are as your father has said
they're the lost boys generation right
they are they're dropping out they have
are purposeless they're not going to
college they're not getting are they
getting just like subsistence level jobs
so that they can sort of you know do
what they want to and they're not have
any plans to be a father no plans to be
a husband no plans like that old order
kind of 20th century
uh married monogamous ideal is not even
there's no incentive
for uh certainly this is generation z
and like maybe the latter half of
millennials right now there's no an
incentive for guys to do that so what is
what happens there's more women that are
enrolled in college right now higher
education
they they get more professional degrees
they can go into the american workplace
um
i mean statistically speaking women are
like improving themselves where men are
just kind of like you know and we poke
fun at the guys and we say well they
need to take more responsibility for
themselves and while we're having that
conversation women just like you women
just like the the women who work for
robert kiyosaki who i work with as well
they're saying the same thing as you or
you will say i think pretty soon here is
i can't find a guy who is my equal i
can't find a guy who has his [ __ ]
together i can't find a guy who is
economically attractive i can't find a
guy who is you know whatever your
prerequisite is and the reason for that
is because you're very intelligent and
you went to college and you have i don't
know how much money i don't know how
much you're worth but you make a good
chunk of change so by doing that and by
improving yourself and building yourself
up into who michaela peterson is or you
know whoever you're you know sort of
strong independent alpha female is
um you have less and less opportunity to
get with her who is going to be that
much just even fractionally above you in
sexual market value because women
conflate sexual market value with
personal worth right now and so for me
to say this and i've said this and it
frustrates the hell out of the women
that i talk to uh who are part of robert
kiyosaki's crew
they're just like you they went to
college in some cases they've got like a
you know at least a four-year degree in
some cases even like you know
post-graduate kind of stuff
and they're making money and they're
like i'm frustrated i can't find the
right guy i can't find anybody right now
or they don't want to have anything to
do with me and it's because they have
built themselves up to what they are
that they become less attractive to the
guys who would want to get with them in
the first place
simply through evolutionary biological
reasons that they don't want to get with
a woman like that again intelligence you
just said a moment ago
and it sort of debilitates those guys so
what so along comes royal tomasi and he
says well
ladies you're gonna have to dumb
yourself down
and no woman wants to do that because
their entire personality and everything
they've invested their egos in is
professionality their money and
everything else that that a gynocentric
feminine you know primary social order
taught them would make them more
impressive would make them more
attractive and it's exactly that would
make men more attractive but it does not
make women more attractive
so now you've got this generation of
women who are these high-powered you
know at least perceptually anyways uh
intelligent um
in some cases single mothers um in uh
with a professional degree with with
some money and everything else and
they're frustrated as hell at these guys
that we want to say man up man up man up
when we've been telling them for
generations to man down
and now women are at a point where
there's
i mean was it uh morgan stanley was
talking about the the rise of the she
economy they have this it's actually a
full blog site right now for the stats
and that by 2030 women between the prime
working demographic between 25 and 45
years old 45 of them will be single and
childless their entire lives because
they don't want to get with the average
woman
it doesn't want to have anything to do
with the average guy
and so that's the that's and so i agree
with you 100 the smarter you are the
more professional you are the more money
you've got everything else that those
are attraction cues for men
not for women
so when when men are attracted they're
looking they're looking for a woman who
is between the ages of say like 23 and
25 years old that's why i pegged that as
the the prime sexual demographic or
sexual peak value for women
during that that period that's why i
pegged that a long time ago
um and now
you know people are suddenly realizing
here we are you know a generation later
that that's what's happening so you've
got your work cut out for you
add a child to that and yeah it's you're
you're probably going to be part of that
demographic i was just mentioning
well i guess we'll we'll find out but i
don't know if the alternative for me
would be
don't do anything and dumb yourself down
so that someone will be more attracted
to you and no one else is good
no one else is going to do that either
that's like yeah so i don't know
how to solve that problem that's a
problem
but and i've thought about that too and
i think the birth control pill has
something to do with that but
but i don't know how to solve that
problem
i don't either but you do realize that
you are in that cohort now right
i mean at 29 years yeah no definitely
definitely but it's better than where i
was
so
i mean maybe it's time to sort of
readjust and reconsider what what your
future plans are yeah i mean i i hope
the best for you i'm not well i'm not
like let's not get too doomsy here like
let's i can see if i was like
a 180 pound
woman with a
you know a couple of kids yourself in
shape you know smoking and
not very smart and being like resentful
at men and angry but i'm none of that
so
we'll see
we'll see what happens but it's still
better than where i was at
um okay we're almost done we're almost
through the video there's another thing
michaela gives her whole family covid at
124.
technically technically scarlett that
same thread so i'm hands off on me but
go ahead continue
peterson finished his treatment in
russia they went to florida and
eventually ended up in serbia where
michaela gave her entire family covid
hospitalizing jordan yet again
okay so ah okay the same that stupid
tweet anyway um yeah no that's not what
happened scarlett was at playgrounds she
brought it home we all quarantined we
quarantined
for actually all of serbia went into
quarantine at the same time because the
the president of the time had been like
kova doesn't exist here the election is
upcoming he opened everything everything
opened and then
he won he shut down the entire of serbia
people rioted and we went into
quarantine we quarantined for 14 days
and on the 14th day scarlet got a
stomachache and a couple days later
everybody had coveted
fortunately it wasn't that bad
so it wasn't michaela gives everyone
covert but i guess that was from the
tweet and not you
um i don't think
i don't think i have a lot
uh more to say i just i just
took offense to the
you know she's parted all her years away
and now she's found god because she
needs forgiveness because i didn't spend
the last like i haven't partied since i
was 22.
um and i don't miss it i hate even at
the time it's not doesn't make you feel
good it's like yeah being drunk is fun
but
you know it's not
it's not good like waking up early
accomplishing a whole bunch and
sleeping getting your sleep
from the schedule straight
i worked in the wine and spirits
industry for about 25 years and i
yes i i'm glad i had really good mentors
at that time
um yeah i i spent a lot of people ask
well what
know i'll get this stuff well i i have
two degrees i've got a degree in fine
arts and i've got a degree a bachelor's
degree in uh behavioral psychology
that's where my background is anyways um
and with the fine arts with it
[Music]
with an mm-hmm on at least the uh the
psychology side of things is with that
emphasis on personality uh studies so
um and then i i ended up double majoring
actually because i was talking with a
lot of guys at that time uh in what
would become the manosphere i guess um
this is back in like remember this is in
like early 2000s like 2002
and um so i originally took
psychology because it was helping me i i
went to college late in life i was in my
30s when i finally finished up my
college you know days
um and i was already i'd already had a
pretty successful career in uh graphic
design and then i was art director for
like casinos and working for liquor
brands as well
and um
and so i was always out even when i
wasn't
even when i was out of sort of like my
party years i was still in clubs and
doing promos and things like that so i
was like
student of uh human behavior let's just
say and i always had to be sober at all
of these these events right because i'm
working it i have to to be there for for
promotional you know reasons
um and so i'm there and i just you know
i take mental notes and then i would
take them back and i would either blog
about them or i'd write about them on
the so-swap forums and we would have uh
long discussions uh over the course of
almost like 10 years now this is back in
the days when seduc the seduction
community like uh mystery and and uh
neil strauss and and the game and all
that other stuff was going on now i
wasn't involved in that because a lot of
people think that i'm like a dating
coach or a relationship expert or
something i know but i had a keen
interest in what they were talking about
because it was relating with what i was
studying
in college at the time
so i was in the clubs i was watching
this happen and i was dragging i was
sort of like um like diane fossey you
know gorillas in the midst like and
watching what the humans are doing and
writing this down and like you know
and then reporting it back to to the
forums that i was participating in at
that time and so i'll i have a very keen
interest in evolution psychology um i if
i was to be star struck by anyone i'm
sorry it wouldn't be your dad it would
be god sod
god saw would be the one that i would be
like you know like almost nervous to
have on my show
because i really like his work um and
then you know i read your dad i read uh
uh dr stephen pinker uh steve stewart
williams uh robert henderson's a really
good follower of mine i i really like
rob henderson yeah rob rob's really kind
of coming into his own but i think one
of the frustrating things for a lot of
guys maybe maybe your dad included
is when you become like a clinical
psychologist right now you can't help
but get into what we're doing right now
which is what i've called the hustle
economy we have to get into youtube you
have to be have to have a presence on on
social media you have to and you you're
already doing i know you know this
because you're already handling your
dad's sort of you know pr i guess in
that respect but when you got a guy who
like steve stewart williams or or god
sod or this guy or even uh with dr david
buss these are guys who have put a lot
of time of work into this stuff yeah and
now
they're they're having to sort of join
this yeah econ this hustle called the
hustle economy like the tates are
definitely a hustler economy i am um and
it doesn't necessarily have to be like
relationship coaches or anything like
that it can be like fitness it can be
money it can be you know real estate
whatever it is or or religion for that
matter like most churches most like
certainly in america anyways evangelical
churches and stuff have to have a blog
they have to have you gotta what live
stream your services and things like
that it's it's all part of that same
economy
yet when you're a clinical psychologist
and you've gone to school for i don't
know eight 12 years something like that
and now you're competing online with
other guys who have that same kind of
brand of me
then that can be kind of it'll rattle
your cage if you're especially if you're
old school if you're like 20th century
thinker right and you you got your
degree say like in the 90s or the 80s
even and now you're kind of thrust into
you know the 21st century in 2021 and
you're having to be another voice
amongst oh and
those voices are actually quoting you
but they're still you know they're out
performing
that gets kind of tough for them but
it's
my my background is is such that um
i've been in pretty unique um situations
where i can be out uh you know like i
said at clubs or i can be out at uh
promos or you know martini fest or
whatever um or promoting stuff for
casinos and such um because i'm in
nevada as you know um but so i've done
that for most of my life and uh at the
same time i've been married for 25 years
my daughter is 23 years old um you know
a lot of people want to dis disqualify
what i have to say because i'm married
or else they want to disqualify what i
say because uh i'm you know i'm not red
pill i'm not red pill enough for like
sort of these black pill doomers and i'm
not red pill enough for like traditional
conservatives but because i happen to be
married
the same time it's like i'm still have a
unique position as in in my life where
i'm you know putting these things into
practice and then putting this sort of
what we call red pill awareness into
into practice as well
and really that's what motivated the
publishing of the first book
so the first book is really the what i
thought were the core principles of all
the concepts and like the epiphany
phases one um we talked about uh i think
you've been your father maybe not by
this name but your father would
understand uh the war bride's dynamic um
what is that warbridge dynamic is that
um you you know we are human beings are
still the same critters we were
back in and a hundred thousand years ago
right we
we still have the same machinery we
still have the evolutionary firmware of
our
ancestors in fact that's what's getting
us i think anyways is getting us into
trouble in 21st centuries because
technology sort of exceeded our excuse
me our ability
to cope with it mentally
so when we talk about like porn
addictions where we talk about like
women advocating yeah
media
our
our evolutionary firmware
can't process that or doesn't know
enough to sort of keep up with that and
so we feel the effects of it as as a
result but when i'm talking about like
say the warbridge dynamic um it's from
human tribalism is what it is um when we
talk about how like early tribes
men would you know get together make war
on another tribe kill off all the men
kill off all the boys and then take all
of the you know viable fertile women and
then introduce them into their tribe and
then mate with them because they still
had mating value and that's what we call
the war brides dynamic and it's one of
the reasons why guys will ask me like
how come
how come my girlfriend got over me so
quick after we broke up and i go well
it's it's part of women's evolutionary
firmware to be able to sort of you know
shift from one guy over to another guy
for survival and you know viability
anyways and that's a vestige of our sort
of ancestral past so same way with like
food for example we didn't have the same
access to
like high
calorie content food
when we were hunters and gatherers but
now we do and now we have an epidemic of
obesity
where like 75 of the u.s population is
overweight obese and that's because our
biologies process
you know calories that was evolved a
hundred thousand years ago when food was
scarce and we needed you know sugar was
a great quick you know energy hit to get
you away from i don't know the
saber-tooth tiger
and so that's a vestige of our sort of
ancestral past well there's other
vestiges i should say of our sort of our
mental wiring and that's one of them so
when i talk about the the war brides
dynamic it's women's sort of innate
ability to
um to fall in love with their captors
let's just say it's like stockholm
syndrome i guess um you can also compare
that to hybristophilia which is um women
falling in love with guys who are like
convicted felons and you know in some
cases killers in prison
to the point where we have to create
laws to separate female prison guards
from the male prison population because
that happened too often
so that's that's a dominance thing
though that women are just attracted to
dominant men and it just goes overboard
sometimes another vestige right violence
is sexy
it is
absolutely sexy a a man's ability
called demonstrating higher value in our
ancestral past the best way for a guy to
demonstrate higher value kill
dude that guy down and now he's no
but
another
longer a competitor or like you know uh
uh club that guy into submission and
that was a selected for
uh survival trait for women and that's
not that it's like we go oh my gosh or
haven't we evolved past that yeah but i
think even your dad will say that you
know your your our biologies right now
sets the
the the operative state for us it sets
the uh the conditions of the game can we
choose to play the game differently yeah
absolutely but those are still the
conditions of the game so when i talk
about like uh on my channel i talk about
the human machine then i talk about like
mental firmware which is sort of like
our operating system that we come out of
the womb with that we have natural
proclivities as men and women and then
there's like our programming which is
gray matter right it's what we learn
from from our parents from our from our
schools from society in general to like
our sort of our programming can the
programming override the the machine and
the
the firmware absolutely but again those
are still the conditions the machine is
what it is
yeah okay
um do you think do you think your book
so i haven't
i follow a number of people who kind of
do
and i don't know exactly what your
category
i don't know where i'm at either to be
honest i don't yeah so but
anyway i follow you and
what it appears like in the comments of
your videos and on twitter is that you
have and lots of fault people's
followers do this but you seem to have a
lot of like
angry men who follow you
and do you think it's possible that the
way that you talk about women maybe
in your book or online encourages kind
of this
just almost like disgust towards women
that aren't interested in these men
i have fielded this question so many
times i yeah i can't even remember how
many times i have in fact i just did a
video on
exactly this topic uh last wednesday
um there's a a very notorious notorious
but a very notorious um
i guess vlogger now whose name is
stardust he also has a channel i think
it's called thinking ape and he was
proposing the same question he was
saying that you know don't you think
that um all these guys like the red
pills poisoned and there's like guys
shouldn't
um
be uh aware of this stuff because it
leads them down a dark path right it
makes them like nihilistic it makes them
hopeless it makes them despondent
and um
and how guys such as myself or you know
whoever who are present i don't i try to
present what i talk about in as neutral
and as objective away as as like nuts
and bolts as i can i don't do judgment
calls on my show okay
in the story i just pre i connect dots
and i have a joke you know i just work
here i i should show you i feel like i
show you the thing but here
well wait wait i feel like on that video
that video you did of me
in the middle there was a whole bunch of
judgments it's like oh we're not allowed
to judge women you know no we are there
to judge women
and trying to optimize that and i wasn't
really focused on
a long-term relationship because i was
23 and i was focused on other things and
i was like you know what i have time to
figure that out later like i'll figure
that out uh by the time i maybe 26 or 27
or 28 even
and i can start thinking about that but
i ended up having to think about that a
lot
okay we know this is [ __ ]
i'll explain to you why this is [ __ ]
right here this is self
rationalizing [ __ ] this is making
your necessity a virtue
[ __ ]
and we'll see exactly why this is here
just a moment but
here you go faster
because
scarlett came around
now that's interesting that puts a lot
of pressure on a relationship though and
when i think about so i look at you and
i could be totally delusional i don't
know you well but when i look at you it
seems like a lot of thought goes into
the decisions that you make
and so as you approached marrying andre
given the sort of complexities of having
a child did that weigh in the decision
like did you were you more prone to
marry him because he was the father of
your child or were you like no that
doesn't matter
oh no 100
i was really i was really stressed out
about being an unmarried mom
like really really i'm sure
you know societally pressured into it
oh yeah
and you know what um this was a bit
skewed because
if it was me now and i went back in time
i probably wouldn't i certainly wouldn't
have felt that way here we go but i'm
much more confident now at the time i
was dealing i was actually dealing with
serious this gets complicated serious uh
ssri withdrawal
so my anxiety was ridiculous so i was
thinking about a whole bunch of things
that i shouldn't have been concerned
about and that most certainly influenced
my decision-making at the time because
you had an impending sense of doom
yeah because i had an impending sense of
doom okay
keep that
write that down chill here we go hey
hello there children how's it going
write that down impending sense of doom
write that down put that in your
notebooks kids we're going to be coming
back to that here very shortly let's say
what i was talking about is i was trying
to
give an objective understanding of how
we interpret judgment
right now when we talk when we talk
about judging women or like uh you'll
find this out on fresh and fit that
whole their entire show really is i mean
the success of their show anyways is
rooted in holding women accountable hold
it like i just held you accountable just
a minute ago i told you i was giving you
a primer for fresh and fit here um
that's
when when that is presented to women
like the the data that i just told you
about like i told you about the the uh
the morgan stanley uh thing i told you
about statistically speaking at 29 years
old with a child
the odds of you finding a guy that is
going to be you know
a good match for you at that point like
there's there's numbers there's data
sets for this i can't really give it to
you because they're doing zoom but
i can give you the data sets and what
i've heard when you start using rational
language
with
in an emotional argument there's there's
a real disconnect there because that's
where judgment comes in we hear this all
the time you'll hear this in every
damn netflix series and every movie and
everything that's been in popular
culture certainly for the last 20 years
which is very it's what i call
non-judgmentalism
it is don't judge me but and that's how
you start the conversation right don't
judge me but blah blah blah blah blah
there is a ver there's like an
imperative
uh in well as far as i'm concerned in a
in a like a female primary gynocentric
social order there's an imperative to
not be judged for your actions to not be
judged for the things that you've done
regardless of the consequences however
we hold women to a different standard
than we do for men when it comes to that
judgment if i said i did this thing i
did this really shitty thing and uh but
don't judge me as a guy
guys are going to judge me because i
have a burden of performance and my
respectability comes from what i do if
women do have like say hey i made some
mistakes in the past and you know now
i'm getting right with god i'm back in
church i'm doing this i'm doing that and
don't judge me but and then that we're
far more
willing to be non-judgmental with women
than we are with men that's what i was
pointing out not that i was saying okay
guys here's what you do i'm known for
not giving prescriptions i don't have 12
rules for life i'm not going to give you
a a
you know a step by step thing but what i
am going what i do give guys is i give
them tools i give them tools to use to
improve their lives and to build
something with it
so when i again this is something i say
all the time is i'm not in the business
of making men better men i'm in the
business of men making themselves better
men by giving them the tools and giving
the rational understanding of their
position in the game that they happen to
be in
so
what the problem with that and you
probably understand this as well is guys
are looking for a step by step they're
looking for a formula they're looking
for something that's going to like okay
i finally found the secret you want to
know why this stuff is so marketable or
your dad's book is so mark or both of
them are so marketable is because guys
are looking for that step-by-step thing
that's why 12 rules sounds great all i
gotta do is follow these and have a good
life
well yeah but you'll be a jordan
peterson man and i'm not looking to make
tomasi men what i want to do is give
guys this realistic objective like
information so they can make educated
decisions about their lives to give them
tools to build a better life in where
they're at now are are guys
like ready for this most guys aren't and
i did i agreed with stardust most guys
are not ready to be woken up they're not
ready to sort of be unplugged from the
matrix as we call it um but it's not me
that's going to wake up the most men
it's the internet right now we have
access to information again remember
always talking about genetic lag we have
access to information
in such a capacity now that in human
history we've never had this
in some cases that's great right i can
go and write a book
you know as rola thomas and i can you
know publish it you know through amazon
i can do all these great things that i
couldn't do before but there's also
downsides to it like addiction to porn
um addiction to social media um there's
or maybe you've got guys who get really
despondent and really nihilistic even
though i try to be as objective
and you know arbitrarily say uh
impartial let's just say uh in
presenting this stuff well some guys
aren't ready for that because their
state
seems kind of hopeless where they're at
as you were saying before you're very
smart girl right on what your iq is but
certainly above average
most guys they're they're at average i
mean what's the bell curve right you've
got those guys right there and a lot of
those guys aren't going to say oh this
is great now i know all this stuff now
i'm red pill aware now i can build a
better life for myself they don't do
that they want they'll say well i'm it's
it's hopeless i'm going to take myself
out i'm going to i'm going to just be a
hermit i'm going to go monk mode
whatever their response to it is
that's why i say it's better to be in a
position where you can sort of be a
guide and help these guys sort of
see what this information is and how
they can use it
uh to their own betterment
most of these guys are discontent and as
i've said before is i believe that the
human condition is discontent and we can
deal with that either constructively or
destructively so you're always going to
be discontent why not build something
better why not be more creative why not
build you know be the positive side of
discontent is great i think because you
can that discontent pushes you on to the
next goal
equally speaking guys who aren't ready
for that can go oh
i'm just going to sedate myself with you
know porn and weed and you know video
games which is the popular you know
concept that we say oh these guys need
to man up and they're just not taking
responsibility that's the that's the
destructive discontent that i talk about
so you got that and then my last
question is this is and i i pose this to
anybody who says
oh well you know your stuff seems to be
really negative well it's only negative
in the terms that you think that it
would benefit like say yourself or
benefit women or it seems very negative
towards women because we have for the
longest time
promoted the interests of women it's
what i call the the empowerment
narrative that's we've given them title
ix we've given them you know no fault
divorce it's like if you look at from
say like the advent of hormonal birth
control the the sexual revolution and
you look at all this you know put women
in the workplace and now we got you know
women who are professionals who have
babies who
you know uh have got a an education and
they can't find a man
that is a
a product a result of what i call the
empowerment narrative is that for the
better or for the worse i've heard your
dad say that we're still in the midst of
this experiment and that's where we're
at the experiment was okay here's
hormonal birth control we have given we
basically given control
of the reproductive process to women
unilaterally to women at this point
through you know uh on-demand abortion
through uh the idea at least that women
can control you know the
reproductive rights reproductive you
know choice we do all that
and so now we here we are in 2021
and we have the products of that but we
don't want to look back and say what led
up to this we don't want to we don't
want to look back at the history and say
how do we how do we get those numbers
how do we get those spikes and you know
divorce and how do we get those um those
the decline of marriage right now
marriage is at its lowest ebb since they
started keeping numbers back in 1890.
and so why is that well we do we want to
say well it's men and they're not taking
responsibility no it's a it's a
combination of all kinds of things
they've cast data where we're at right
now so what i've so the basic question
is this and most people are going to
have to answer this whether they're red
pill where they hear it from me or you
or anybody else is would you rather be
happy or would you rather be right
because you can stick your head in the
sand you can all say you know what i'm
gonna log off i'm gonna have a great day
out on this on the slopes because it
just snowed i'm gonna take my snowmobile
out i'm not gonna think about jack [ __ ]
okay i can do that but i'm still in the
back of my head saying okay
you gotta do post i got to do this i got
to stay on top i got to stay in my in
you know plugged in so i'm not ignorant
of the information that could you know
affect my life or whatever but when it
comes to the fundamental question is now
that we have access to
let's just say more accurate information
and again that can be politically
religiously um personally uh you know
romantically whatever i have more access
now in the 21st century than i ever did
before and now that i'm aware of this
it's like
the tree that fell off the you know
the the or it's gonna be the fruit that
fell off the tree that eve ate right you
know i can i've got knowledge of good
and evil all of a sudden well now i've
got that what do i do with that
information how do i live better
and so
that's the problem i think that guys
like stardust probably yourself it seems
like these guys get really negative and
they do
but they're going to have to deal with
it it's not me that's doing it and
leading guys astray it's they're going
to get this information whether i am
here or i'm not
so it's uh it you know to me anyways it
seems like it would be better to have a
guide than to just sort of try to sort
things out yourself
[Music]
okay i i guess so i i i think i agree
with most of what you
just said um especially the fact that
people need access to statistics and
information properly um i guess i'm
the way i come at it is so birth control
for instance
most women and they're not generally
aware of this most women they start
taking the pill they get massively
depressed and like
mentally ill to be completely honest and
so that hasn't been advantageous for
women either in fact if they're the ones
on it they're the ones that can be crazy
and that is a side effect that hits most
people but most people started so young
that they don't know that it's happening
to them that's awful and people should
be aware of that information before
going on the pill they should be aware
of the fact that their sexual
preferences change while they're on the
pill like this information should be
spread around like what you're doing but
i don't 100 agree
yeah i i don't think the fault is you
know i don't think the fault is
necessarily with women and i don't think
the way to solve the problem is to go
back
i don't think there is any going back
you can't give women education the
ability to work in the workplace and
then tell the women who are super
productive oh no you have to stay home
like you can't do these things so we
need to come up with way forward
yeah with all the information so that
people are aware hey if you wait until
you're 30 you're going to have a harder
time having kids and that's not you know
society's fault that's just biology
right and so people should have access
to this information but when you give
people access to the information it
shouldn't end up with
anybody being angry about it right and i
see in in your comments there are a lot
of oh you know like disgusted disgusted
women disgusted single mothers when
you know the way society is right now is
really making everybody suffer
yes 100 agree but and you're looking at
a demographic of guys that we call like
i guess the most extreme end of mgtows
like men going their own way um there's
also sort of like the black pill which
is like it's all hopeless
and i there is i think that when guys go
from being
what we call blue pill to being red pill
right they're unplugging from this old
way of thinking about things that they
believed in an old order way of thinking
they believed in what i call the in the
old set of books it's like a rule set
that guys have believed for a long time
was
what everybody else was using and so
they say okay well if i do these things
or follow this rule set
then i'll i'll find a good girl and
she'll love me just as much as i love
her and it's you know that that disney
pixar kind of soul mate crap
and then they realize either
generally through a point of trauma or
crisis that
people aren't playing by that rule set
and i think they're becoming like more
and more men right now especially you
know now 21 years into the 21st century
are becoming more aware of that
and in for some guys they get really
upset and angry and and nihilistic and
despondent at that uh i have a i think i
put it in i think i put in my second
book um there is a post and that i i
converted into a chapter and it's called
the the five stages of unplugging and
those five stages are
synonymous with dealing with death right
it's um
it's uh what is it uh denial
anger um acceptance you know you get all
through the fives i forget all the five
steps but you get that you finally get
down to sort of acceptance and then the
sixth step you know that people take it
to is like getting jaded about things
but the second step is getting angry and
i think a lot of people think that the
red pill makes guys angry at women and i
can tell you right now there's
nothing is could be further from the
truth because what happens is when guys
become aware of the new rule set like i
was saying the new order you know
thinking when they become aware of that
they don't get angry at women they get
angry at themselves for having believed
in the old rule set for so long
because for you know depending on how
old the guy is they probably live most
of their lives according to that rule
set and now it's kind of like oh god
damn it now i gotta reset
now i gotta you know erase everything
and i gotta you know figure out how to
make my life work
in this new paradigm
and as i said before most guys don't
have
that creativity they don't know how to
see opportunity in that paradigm because
they're still kind of hung up on the
things that they really wanted
that
were you know just simply not you know
it's their blue pill idealism and those
ideals are gone and they don't know how
to deal with the true nature of men and
the true nature of women and it's
you know fed to them on a daily basis so
especially a younger generation get
really despondent and get really angry
again i said i would argue that it is um
it's more about men getting angry at
themselves
because it's like with opportunity cost
like all of that opportunity all the
things that they could have done the
life they could have lived
had they known this that's where i wrote
the second book because i had so many
guys say role i wish i would have had
your first book before i
got divorced or got married or had kids
i
took this as a major i did you know i
moved to a different country whatever i
wish i would have known that or followed
this girl across you know timbuktu
and so that's why i wrote the second
book because it's sort of a timeline of
what these guys can expect but that was
the most common you know reaction to all
of this and usually as a result of
passing through that anger phase into
the acceptance phase and now what they
do is they use this information to build
better lives or in some cases save their
own lives take the noose off their neck
take the gun out of their mouth i've got
i have a i've got a post called uh was
it the safety net and
in that post there's over a thousand
guys with testimonials in there saying
you know i literally had a date with
death i was literally planning a date
for me to hang myself or you know shoot
myself or whatever i was getting all the
insurance you know in line to make sure
my kids were taken care of and
everything and then i read your book
and i i cancelled that date and now
because of that you know my kids have a
father still to this day and there's
like i said there's over a thousand
comments and that's usually why when
people ask me for testimonials i usually
point them to that
that comment thread
but i i you know we can say well you
know look at the comments on your on
your blog like the comments in your chat
yeah that's going to be there because
people don't want to they don't know how
to deal with or cope with
hard empirical data
and i'm the one giving it to i i happen
to be the one giving it to him but it
doesn't mean that i got a monopoly on
that not by any stretch of the
imagination
okay well i don't have anything against
red-pilled guys i think that's the only
way to go
and it also like it makes men more
attractive if they're aware of what's
going on so i'm i'm all for that it's
the kind of resentment that can come
along with it that i think just breeds
into the problem well i think we think
of we think along with it sometimes not
for everybody like you said for for a
small percentage of people
yeah yeah well again and those are the
ones who are the ones who are going to
leave a drive-by comment they're the
ones who are going to go yeah well you
know just uh you know [ __ ] ain't
nothing but tricks and hoes right that
that that'll be the comment just because
they want to feel heard you also notice
and because maybe you don't know this
because you're not in my my sphere i
guess
but whenever i see guys who sort of
leave these like one hit comments or
something it's usually that same kind of
mentality it's guys who just they don't
even i i mean literally i've done um
youtube shorts i'm sure you know what
youtube shorts yeah like like 59 second
videos
and usually what i do is i clip them out
of other videos because i think they're
you know they're pithy and whatever i
put them up um when i started i stopped
doing those by the way
but when i started doing those i thought
they were gonna be little bite-sized
info bites for these guys and what i was
finding is that people who were
commenting on those and they you know
the the viewership was fantastic on
those
what i found was that you could clearly
tell by the guy's comment that they
didn't even watch a 59 second video they
just saw the title and they saw like
maybe the first two or three comments
and they're like yeah man [ __ ] say
another but drinks and hoes bye you know
and they don't they don't look and they
won't spend the time to watch a youtube
short but they will spend the time
probably longer time to type out a
comment because they think that they
know what i'm talking about by the
thumbnail or the title of the video they
look at the first three comments and
then they go and chime in as well
that's the mentality that's it's it's
what i call the tldr generation it's
like this generation of
men and women who have adhd at least
because of social media they don't stop
to think about things they don't take
any time to watch even a 59 second video
they would just simply go and comment
because they want to feel heard they
just want to have something that says
i'm frustrated and i'm going to put this
on this in this stupid short that i
didn't watch you know it's like when it
took you like 59 seconds you probably
saved yourself from embarrassment or
getting uh you know self ownage right
had you even watched that but guys don't
care because they just type it in and
they're on to the next one
because that they want to feel like
somebody out there in the you know the
internet verse you know actually gives a
[ __ ] about what they say
so in your book or in any of your books
do you give people tools about how to
move forward once they're aware of how
hard life is i think that's all i give
them as tools pretty much how they
interpret that is different i don't say
here's how you do these things
i don't do prescriptions i don't say
here's the here's the
the one size fits all here's the rules
like people always and people love this
because i i have in my first book i've
got the nine iron rules of tamasi and
that's what most of my my critics and
the people who love me to death uh
fixate on because they think of them as
being sort of like a step-by-step guide
or some sort of like here's the
it's like the ten commandments right
and i i'm
thinking backwards i probably wouldn't
have named them the nine iron rules of
tomasi now had i had to do it all over
again but uh
though i thought they were you know sort
of universal kind of things for guys to
think about
but um but then i get in trouble for
them because again people only
if they know of those nine-eyed rules
they tend to always misinterpret them or
they interpret them in such a way that
they can straw man me and say oh this is
what he really meant
i don't have a
guide to the universe right and i don't
think i think anybody who's claiming
that they do
um is selling you something now i am an
author now um and so do i sell books yes
i do
however i also sell information
and how guys take that information and
use that to their own benefit is really
kind of up to the individual the reason
why i back off from prescriptions
is because i don't presume to say that
everything that's worked out for me will
also work out for you
i can't tell somebody like i'm i'm 53
years old i can't tell some kid who is
you know 25 years old in south africa or
nepal or japan or whatever
that here's here's a perfect here's
what's going to work for you it's a
universal truth you just do this and
you'll have a good time or you'll be
you'll be set i'm not going to do that
because i don't know what the context of
their lives are i can only give them
like sort of the general
the generalities i guess like here is
women's nature here is men's nature here
is the nature of the game that you are
in here's things to look for here's
things to expect how you use that data
is really up to the individual as i said
before i'm not looking to create tomasi
men i want them to make their own in
fact i say this all the time show me
show me your work show me what you built
show me how you went from being like
single and sexless to having a
girlfriend show me like how you've
developed your business show me how you
have taken this data and used it to your
own benefit because i'm not giving out
like success programs i'm not a success
porn hustler i'm a guy that is just
simply giving you know data here's some
things to think about i connect dots
what do you think of that in fact i say
you know if you think i'm full of [ __ ]
please tell me usually it's like oh
you're a cult leader well that's an
opinion what i want to know is why do
you disagree with this point that i made
in the book why do you disagree with
what i'm saying right here on this
particular tenet
okay because then we can have a
conversation then we can actually sort
of suss that out and say well maybe
here's something i thought about maybe
you didn't think about but we don't do
that in this generation because
quick hit template
lists of ways to go from hero to zero
that sells that's why like people keep
saying well you're so under monetized
role i'm just now talking to you
michaela i'm just now
just now getting into like working with
robert kiyosaki and just now you know
people are starting to take notes i've
been doing this for 20 freaking years
but people don't you know they'll quote
me or they'll use terminology that
they've heard from my book or something
i said at some point that somebody else
you know third party might have said but
they don't realize where it came from
and the reason for that is because i
don't i don't sell prescriptions
if i was like tony robbins and said hey
guys let's all you know feel better
about ourselves and put ourselves first
that sells tickets to you know sell out
arenas
but what doesn't is hard empirical data
again would you rather be happy or would
you rather be right
if i'm looking at like people who are
selling prescriptions and how do i go
forward how do i make a better you know
life for myself
i don't think anybody can answer that
except for the individual except for
that person how are you going to use
this data for your own benefit
so that's why i'm not doing you know
tony i could very easily go do tony
robbins seminars i could very easily go
and you know do a world tour and say
here's the prescription for a better
life but i'm not going to do that
because i think it's up to the
individual to sort of cater that to
their own lives
i think that's exactly what my dad's
doing on his door
it's up to the individual here are some
tools as in tell the truth don't get
resentful but i think that that maybe
might be an overlap with what you're
saying
well i mean and then sometimes i i've
said this before that the red pill
doesn't exist
so that men will hate women it exists so
men won't hate women for what they can
never be to them and to reassess what
they would think what their presumptions
were in the past sometimes that's
difficult sometimes that's hard
sometimes there's resentment sometimes
guys get nihilistic because they think
that it's hopeless i can never be like
i can never be like andrew tate i could
never be a kickboxer i could never look
like that i don't have a lamborghini i
could never be that and that's been
really my sort of mission i guess for
the last like you know a couple of years
is to make the red hill more relatable
to everybody not just
guys you know driving a mclaren in miami
but like guys who are working on a
tractor in oklahoma
need this at just as much as anybody
else and so i'm trying to make really
what i'm trying to do anyways is make
this data available to the everyman to
like so it's relatable
um and i think it it can be but it can't
be if i make it so specific that say
okay here's 10 ways to
be a you know playboy in in miami that
that's going to sell to a certain
demographic but not certainly not
everybody
and again it goes back to what i was
saying before
the tl dr generation too long didn't
read i don't know if you want tldr means
but it's this um it's this this we have
such short attention spans right now
like i said people won't even you know
watch a 59 second video
so that's the that's the mentality
that i have to deal with as a guy who's
sort of like brokering in information i
guess
so for me like i can understand
excuse me why guys
want
those easy answers they want a
prescription
because they go okay okay so here's the
solution here's the i want a better life
how do i get a better life right and
then they get like oh here's 10 rules
for me to be okay i'm going to follow
these rules and they get down to the
tenth rule and they go
okay or whether or not they even get to
the tenth rule is is kind of like in
question because after they get to like
rule number three they're like throw
this away and find something else
because it the attention span is not
there it's tl dr
so does it actually do something well
maybe it did maybe it didn't maybe it
improves improves their lives maybe it
didn't you're going to hear the success
stories but what you're not going to
hear is the guys who just read the first
three three rules and threw it out the
window or like you know self-help books
or you know that's the number one by the
way that's the number one
um
genre of books for psychology is
self-help
and why is that bad
why is i'm saying it's bad it's the
desire to want to improve your life not
bad that's how you're going about it
some people do it through religion some
people do it through psychology some
people just do it through like
perseverance and like a jocko will inc
right i mean just get up at 4 30 in the
morning and go to get in the squat rack
which i think is a probably pretty good
idea
but um
how what's your therapy what's your
meditation what's your what's your
program
uh maybe it's making a [ __ ] ton of money
in crypto you know i like maybe that's
where where you're you know where you
would thrive i guess
but my my point is this is that even
like having discussions of like well
what about positivity and what about
giving these guys a program well i mean
i can get i could do that i could start
creativity though that doesn't ever work
for anyone i don't think well again
would you rather be happy or would you
rather be right and most people choose
right now because they can't choose
anything else because they're always
plugged into social media they're always
plugged into this you know this new
database and they can't escape
what they used to i mean some guys do
right i mean there's still guys who play
world of warcraft and live in their sort
of like escapisms
um there's guys who get addicted to porn
and that's their escapism uh or alcohol
uh prescription drugs what do you name
the escape guys still get get stuck in
that because they give up as a result of
be of too much reality human beings
can't handle too much reality and so
again would you rather be happy or would
you rather be right it's ignorance bliss
or is it not and that no matter whether
it's in your relationships or in your
you know your finances or your family or
whatever else that's a question that
every human being on planet earth is
going to have to answer pretty soon
when we look at like um when you look at
covid the covid response right now i
can't believe i'm going to talk about
this
when we talk about like the covet
response and just how
the hysteria
that has sort of come in the wake of it
right now that you're looking at an
emotional response versus rational data
you're look it's exactly what i'm
talking about here just in a different
theater just in a different arena so we
have data we have the answers we have
everything we see this every day people
go oh you're an anti-vaxxer and they
want to turn it into sort of this
emotional appeal and they want us versus
them and and they want to have a
two-tiered society and let's go put
people in covet concentration camps and
talk to them
like i would go like you know that's
kind of what those guys in 1938 then
germany did we don't that doesn't even
occur because they're so invested in the
emotional appeal like i want to be happy
and then the other people who are
anti-vaxx or who are like hey i'm not
gonna like for me example i'm not gonna
take the vaccine because i read the data
and i see what's going on and to me
making an empirical reasonable rational
decision is like i'm not gonna i don't
have anything to do with that it looks
to me like it's a you know genetically
modified or a genetically engineered
vaccine for a genetically engineered
virus so
when i look at that and i see the data
and i know what you have a
rudimentary understanding of like what
crispr is you know i look at that and i
go no i'm not going to do it don't care
and it's not a religious reason and it's
not i don't want any religious exemption
i don't it's not because i'm like
you know better than anybody else i'm
just making a rational reasonable
decision for myself well at the same
time people want to like firebomb my
house
because they think i'm an anti-vaxxer
because that's their emotional response
to my rational reasonable response
and that's just one arena now put that
into politics put that into religion put
that into your personal relationships
when you're trying to reproduce and you
know have a good life with a wife and a
kid
so you're going to have to answer that
fundamental question would you rather be
right or would you rather be happy
and right now i think we're getting the
point where nobody can be happy because
we have such access to data that we it
preoccupies us all the time
with our very short attention spans
yes
i agree
i think that um i i can understand where
you're coming from from
you know
um not being impressed with a
prescription for people to improve their
lives but i think some of the
fundamental ways of living even some of
the stuff the bible teaches you
fundamental ways to organize your life
can help people so i think what my dad's
trying to do with his book isn't hey
follow these 10 easy steps i don't think
any of the steps are easy like try
telling the truth
all the time i think what's funny about
your dad's work is that it is it used to
be common sense
it used to be something that yeah yeah
like why why do i need like i really
what do i need to read this for this
just like who doesn't know this right
well a lot of people don't know this
yeah you know a lot of people and um i
think that's one of the i think that's
part of the appeal of guys who just have
like this nuts and bolts you know salt
of the earth uh take on things now the
other thing is this is you know if you
well the reason i wrote the fourth book
on religion is exactly that i'm not
saying that they're like people come at
me and they go
are you [ __ ] on religion you know
like are you [ __ ] on on christianity
or islam or judaism or i'm like no i'm
not i say oh so then it's uh so you're
[ __ ] on atheism no no i'm not i'm
i'm analyzing this i'm i'm an analyst
i'm not a i'm not proselytizing for
anything i mentioned that in the very
beginning of the introduction of the
book i said if you are an atheist
thinking that this is going to validate
your views you are in for a big
disappointment and i said if you are a
you know christian muslim jew hindu
whatever krishna sikh whatever and you
think that this is going to validate
your views you are also going to be very
disappointed because this is not to say
oh well this religion is red pill and
this one is not that's not what i did
all i did was analyze
current trends i analyzed religions from
a red pill perspective
again it's not
people and you'll notice that that's the
first impression people have an
emotional response to like oh well i
don't want to read this because i think
rolo's [ __ ] on my religion or i
think rollo is not recognizing atheism
i'm like no i'm giving you an objective
understanding and objective analysis at
least from my perspective anyways of
what's going on
but that's the initial response so yeah
i understand what your your dad's saying
i understand also you know in religion
you could quote islam there's lots of
great wisdom in islam there's lots of
great wisdom in judaism they're in
krishna and whatever you know you can
find little bits and pieces that say
okay well they they figured this out a
long time ago
but as i said before common sense is at
a premium right now so ancient wisdom is
probably at a much higher premium as
well
so
when i talk about um
red pill principles i try to couch it in
terms of like i've said this and i don't
know i apparently this isn't sinking in
but i've said it enough times i believe
that men and women are compliments to
one another
i think and you don't need the bible to
tell you that i mean it's nice to hear
to read it in your bible for sure but
men and women are compliments to one
another from an evolutionary perspective
and sometimes religion and empirical
evolutionary hard data you know
rationalism whatever they coincide they
actually
suddenly come together right so if i say
well men and women are innate
complements to one another even if you
look at our like our you know our
neurological wiring if you look at fmri
scans of men's brains and women's brains
there are gender differences or
biological gendered differences that are
hard data the blank slate is [ __ ]
social constructionism is [ __ ]
but when you present that to people
and they don't they don't want to hear
that you know that's when they have an
emotional response or they could go the
other way i said exactly this to elijah
elijah schaefer um last week and i said
you know men and women are innate
evolved compliments to one another i
said my strengths as a man as a
masculine conventionally masculinity
in innately compliments women's
conventional femininity and as i said
before like you can override that with
your learning and your your your
programming but if we go down you get
down to nuts and bolts or you look at
brain scans and you look at innate
gender differences the compliments are
just like this
does that gel with the bible yeah yeah
it kind of does
so do you need do you need uh religion
to tell you that well great if that's
the case then go with it do you need
science or or you know empirical you
know objective objectivism to tell you
that great go with that because it's
true no matter
for either way
so i i said this at the very end of that
book and i'll leave you with this is
i uh there's this little cartoon and it
was this guy
who uh
uh i forget the name of who the
cartoonist was but uh
well it's this guy who looks like he's
like from like kung fu like he's like
trying to find the the the guru master
at the top of the mountain kind of thing
so he can learn how to like throw a
punch or be you know like uh you know
uses uh martial arts or something like
that he finds the guru at the top of
like some you know i guess tibetan
mountain and he says you know master
teach me the ways of you know kung fu
blah blah blah or says how do i throw
the perfect punch and then the the guru
says uh well you um you must um
let go of your conscious mind and go
with your unconscious mind or something
like that and then the aspirin guy says
well why is that and then so the guru
says well because you're using uh
you know
deductive memory are you using uh this
memory instead of that memory you go
through this like really scientific like
explanation as to why you should sort of
you know like so you lose yourself and
lose your consciousness kind of thing
when you're doing things because it's
like implicit memory versus like
deductive memory or something like that
and so he explains it in these really
scientific terms and then the aspirin is
kind of like he's like confused like can
you explain that to me and like in in
like some mystical you know
explanation and he says dwell in your
inner
in-ness and he goes ah thank you master
and then so he understands it and that's
it's funny because you it because it
seems like a joke and everything but
it's funny because it's recognizable so
we need that magical thinking some
people anyways need that magical
thinking to learn something
because it's easier to wrap your head
around if you turn it into some sort of
mysticism but the fundaments the
principles of it are still
valid
and i think it was brett weinstein who
said this he says you know there's a
there is a what's called a metaphorical
truth
um there's things that are true that
aren't actually true but it's best to
believe as if they are true
and i use that quite a bit in that book
um
like he gives the example of like uh
stay away from porcupines because they
can shoot their quills at you
which they can't no no no porcupine can
actually like eject his you know
quills at you but it's best to behave as
if they can so you'll stay away from the
porcupines because if you get a quill in
you it's going to work its way in it's
going to be really painful and you want
to stay away from that so
so objectively empirically speaking no
porcupines can't shoot their quills but
it's best to behave as if they can so
the metaphorical truth becomes
porcupines can shoot their quills it's
the it's the folklore kind of thing
right and then if you take that
principle of metaphorical truth and then
you put it into
master how do i throw the the perfect
punch well i can give you like the the
data and i can tell you like the the
hardcore empirical reasons why that is
but people
they don't want that
they want magic they want woo
you know they want uh they want to be
able to dwell in your inner illness and
if that's how they learn that that truth
is it any different than actually having
learned it from you know books and
having it explained to you in hard data
and so i explained that so if you want
some sort of crossover i think there's a
lot of crossover i get in trouble with
this by the way because um
when i talk about magical thinking
people tend to
um
give me grief about it because they
think that they they
associate it with like atrocities of
religion
and uh and charlatans and there's a lot
of ways to abuse matt you know magical
thinking i guess but magical thinking is
where our imagination is as well so the
same
same element or the same module i guess
that we use in our brain that says hmm i
wonder if there's a god i wonder if
there's things that if there's ghosts i
wonder if there's you know you know ufos
or whatever that same kind of like
capacity to imagine things i think that
that's very very important but it can be
kind of be abused
yes
lots of examples through human history
where it's abused but it's also
necessary so that we can watch great
movies like you know the avengers you
know
or lord of the rings that is a great
movie we have to have we have to have
that magical thinking element to
our biology so that we can
be good storytellers so that we whether
they're true or not you know i guess
it's the metaphorical truth they're
teaching a lesson did that did the lord
of the rings actually happen no but you
can still learn a lot from like the
stories and the things that are going on
in there um or they're relating sort of
the human condition but you have to have
that that imaginary mentality i i
started out the book with uh it was a i
think it was an einstein quote which is
like what's more important um knowledge
or imagination now of course einstein
says oh it's imagination i would argue
that it's both and that goes back again
to reason versus emotion imagination
magical thinking versus empiricism and
data believers versus empiricists
and right now
for those certainly for the last quarter
century maybe even longer than maybe 50
years i guess
we have prioritized emotion above reason
and we're getting to a point right now i
think since year 2000
that because we have access to data work
all of the things that we thought were
true as a result of this sort of
emotionalism and and get in touch with
your feelings and you know getting your
feminine side and express yourself
emotionally and follow your heart
because it'll never fail you it'll lead
you down the right path right whether it
leads you off a cliff or not is
irrelevant but it sounds right your soul
made this and now we have data and now
where it's unignorable and it conflicts
with that old order emotionalists
thinking and that's why you get people
throwing rocks at you over covid that's
why you get people to say well roll is
always negative no i'm just giving you
the example and sometimes it doesn't
taste good because you wanted an
emotional
treat and not a rational reasonable
treat
okay rollo well
thank you very much for coming on
that was fun glad i can clarify things
for you too so
yes i'm probably going to still be out
there searching for my soul mate but
but um but that was good thank you again
for coming on uh if if people want to
find you where should they go uh you can
find me at
therationalmail.com that's my blog
you can also find all four of my books
on amazon just type in the rational mail
in the search engine you'll find out
four of them
i of course have a weekly podcast and
sometimes it's bi-weekly um i
am on at 1 pm pacific 4 pm eastern on my
channel which is called the rational
mail i sometimes do wednesday shows
except for this wednesday because i know
i just be doing this
and then i'm also on a panel show called
rule zero which is every saturday at uh
11 30 a.m uh eastern time
and uh
i'm working on a fifth book right now
actually so uh that's in the works and i
do a lot of you have a title
um i have a working title called the
player's handbook at this point but
that's okay calling it so it's it's more
about you want nuts and bolts there
that's gonna be the nuts and bolts book
um but uh
i think that's it oh and then you can
find me on twitter i am rolotomasi at
rational mail
okay well thank you again for coming on
sure thanks for having me
[Music]
you